all right the button we'll see what's up
waiting don't sound confident
this little extra pours you got a see oh
there goes a snow there you go
alright and we owe your mic just went
crazy but wait we're crazy okay there
you go you go back okay okay good all
right and we owe laughs welcome to the
iron watts podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 137 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about a special guest and
we've got switch on the brink of history
horizon zero dawn the PC Xbox Lockhart
and the crown your Lord segment Game
Awards returns to discuss so we go get
right into it
I wanna introduce it Lord whose content
was first introduced to me by Laurel now
though after PAX East 2019
now this law of one of our bright stars
within the Nintendo community but is
easily one of the most concise game
reviewers along with being a truly
passionate multi-platform gamer
introducing the creator and host of the
flannel Fox and cigar danube youtube
channels the working dad was by far the
longest commute and still the de facto
leader of switchers everywhere new
jersey's finest and making his debut
into the realm of the lord's marvin stir
tips verdict aka the flannel fox how you
doing sir
oh very good very good damn what an
intro good run with the boys basil Uwe
Lord it what you do it's only right we
show you a proper respect here at the
round table
how you doing minute very good ready to
talk nerd switch making history and
killing dinosaur robots on PC man no
doubt that what else we got on what you
could play about oh I've been playing so
I actually just got to a point in The
Witcher 3 where I think I'm ready to
move on but I've just been jam in The
Witcher 3 on switch no first you gotta
quit advance
correctly so that is switcher 3 they
Plato 300 resolution slanderous now
right balefully I gotta say that when I
heard the switcher that's how I sign off
one on my video game reviews I'm like
see you next time switchers when I heard
the first time was like yo can I get no
I actually I was so hyped when they even
like you know rumored The Witcher
possibly coming to the Nintendo switch
for a long time and I was ready to take
that graphic hit which it definitely
took good but I never played even though
I bought The Witcher 3 on xbox one NPC I
never played it on either one I'm just
one of those like oh I got a I got a buy
a game today I got a new that thing it
was on sale dress that later to you guys
I'm assuming one of you guys has played
The Witcher yes oh yeah yeah it got to a
point I'm like 50 hours in on the switch
and I held off play and went for a
really long time because I'm like I'm
not even going down that rabbit hole but
then I started playing goin it's amazing
and but I just have so much gear now
that I feel like every I'm like so Opie
and I like I haven't completed the story
but most of the missions that I go on
now I'm like I'm just gonna like it's
not that hard anymore so I just switched
off and I just bought a ninokuni oh yeah
which is actually the kids name is
Oliver and that's my son's name and I
love the little uh the British little
elephant trunk dude there's a problem
Wally boy how far did you make it in it
I'm um I made a pretty decent I'm almost
finished with it you know Cooney yeah I
just downloaded it Friday morning
so that's your um yes I played it a
little bit on my commute nice but I had
to finish the Irishman on the way home
that was a good movie I actually enjoyed
that I try to stay away from those
little mini card games because when I
play Final Fantasy 8 and I was playing
that little mini card game I got
obsessed with it more than the actual
game itself oh yeah yeah I'm like never
again never again like that's too funny
so it's been a lot of gaming for you
that's good you know me so we go get
into the original Four Horsemen of
gaming those Lords around here at the
roundtable my co-hosts with the core
most my brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror Lord of reviews
and the hub of the young wolf mommy Lord
addict how you doing sir doing pretty
good recovering from the the Pokemon
itis that I had Pokemon action though we
had like discussions this week very
strong discussions it's an average game
know what these people tell you you
different so you just being facetious
I'm serious entrepreneurs it seems that
way that's why I went with ninokuni I
look around with a shield this week and
then I was like I watch too many reviews
and I was like it seems like people
aren't pumped about it oh wait otherwise
this is that's what I'm confused with it
because the sales is off the charts with
it Pokemon yeah but but but there it is
it's back to the polarizing partner
sales is crazy people are saying it is
good some people are saying this average
so I'm thinking that the people that are
real Pokemon heads are saying it's
average at best and other guys is
younger not is good because maybe that's
their first Pokemon game well you know
what I really think it is is everybody
was so excited and like alright I think
that Game Freak is gonna do something
breath of like what what they wanted was
the breath of the wild of Pokemon okay
they're not gonna get it it's just
another Pokemon game so so many people
are let down by that but it's like I
feel like Game Freak needed to either
manage their expectations or people
stopped needing like we need to stop
thinking that every game's gonna be
breath of the wild Pokemon sword shield
is is a shell compared to a Pokemon hold
or cash out the crystal oh she said she
said don't be confused by the sales King
David this
from the apologists Oh Vespa the cells
people like me they said they gonna send
that ground but into buying the game
anyway switch into bushes emojis already
we already start Joe Wow crew baby way
put that coming in hi I know just pretty
much Pokemon Pokemon poking no doubt and
of course we have our most epic gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Damas mr. off my profile
Illuminati and lower patron of the iron
bake mommy nor sovereign how you doing
sir chillin mouse going on brother good
morning
[Laughter]
he said that today when he called me he
thought I was out cold I really wasn't
the Lord no longer been Dunedin FL said
Oh Sunday's
football in the bushes mansion on the
switch obviously been away from home for
a minute little bit of that games pretty
it's so good and then I I said I was
gonna purchase any more games this year
and then one game that I've had my eyes
on that I didn't want to pay 50 bucks
for and I'm sorry but I just didn't a
plague tale innocence there was a lot of
talk about that game early peers good
thing it was 50 I don't know and it
lingers there's kids we've got a review
caught before so I don't even play for
that yeah game
it's pretty cool man I'm really liking
I'm only played maybe like an hour or so
but that's one of the visually
impressive games that came out this year
yeah yes yeah yeah I got you have to see
it or a shot - Sam Tolbert I believe did
that focus home interesting point girl
it's like yeah and the narrative like
seems really really cool so I'm and it
doesn't seem like it's a super long game
either so yeah hopefully one of the
games that actually gets us finished um
so that's pretty much it I want to shout
out this game this is hilarious I was on
em for Jean talked and I ran upon this
this headline this said I am Jesus name
is on Steam now is coming soon it is
cold I am Rihanna
you know what's funny it is a
first-person realistic Messiah simulator
you know what's funny I think I've seen
images of it because shout out to almost
blackly he told his Twitter feed yeah oh
gee head box Xbox car created and some
like religious game I'm like and he was
like these characters are looking very
Wisconsin he's like trying to say that
people don't look like that
they have a singing what he is is on the
cross he's full of energy
a ka the XS gamer ooh the lord of combat
sports king of the statues ooh there's
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement ooh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir oh
who you guys know exactly how I'm doing
today
you know exact listen I try to keep well
as is in tune down with what I was doing
yesterday as much as possible so yeah I
can see the fight at all times I was
giving you round by round I didn't want
to you know actually spoil the fight for
you can go look at highlights I'll go
subscribe to the zone for you frauds um
but um if he wasn't able to do so um I
was just showing you round by round a
lot of people didn't like the fact that
Anthony Joshua came in a little bit
Elena I love the fact that he came in a
little bit Lina I love the fact that he
went in there to avenge his loss he was
embarrassed
you know people when you have one at
such a level that he has one that's
Olympic gold and all the way through he
has been winning championships he's not
my favorite heavyweight don't get that
you know I'm construed by anything my
thing is doing Deonte wild is the true
heavyweight King but I'm not even the
facts but I must say this this man is
highly accomplished and in our first
fight he felt this interested because
the person he was falsified big debut
Miller which I thought would have beat
him tested positive for three banned
substances also so yes three different
banned substances that are totally
it's a faster own we don't win a booster
of control we got to balance out the
test I like this guy was trying to
balance everything he's juggling he was
juggling drugs okay so we got Andy Ruiz
Andy Ruiz was eight weeks off of a fight
that he previously had right so you know
he was begging for the fight and they
gave it to him now this leads me to
believe the only reason why Andy Ruiz
came in the shape that he was in and
ready because he already previously just
had a fight this leads us to believe
because he came in 283 pounds now when I
when I say he did he was disgusting I'm
not saying that his shape I'm not body
shaming the man I'm not saying that I'm
talking about as a profession as a
professional boxer you're supposed to
take your profession and you're supposed
to really this is if this is how you
feed your family then sir they gonna go
hungry because you didn't you didn't sit
there and say you know what I believe in
myself I'm here I'm gonna win you came
in in a nasty sloppy overweight self and
it's it's not body shaming when I'm
saying this I'm saying it because he was
supposed to come in 2:55 mm-hmm he came
in 263 the first fight coming 255 you
know the other guy is training you come
in a little bit leaner you give yourself
a chance to win so people don't call you
a one-shot pony like Buster Douglas
Buster Douglas ate his way out of the
championship good years
they showed a cutaway a picture of a
video of all the people in his house all
these new family members all these new
people out of the woodwork once you have
some money and that changes your
perspective of things you losing for so
long then that you got the wind you
don't know how to hold on to the wind
hate how to get back to the wind he
doesn't like the taste of losing you
sword
the guy didn't have a haircut the guy
had a scruffy beard the guy and he was
you know what it is because he didn't
care about photo shoots even kid you
know how it is calculate
yes good I did see a little bit and I
guess he stuck to the game plan you know
he kept it outside and all that hmm I
just felt like I wasn't impressed I was
right they were showing a press
conference a like you know they have him
he looks like the prototypical hey it
looks like news will be that we just did
they show anyway somebody said like a
creative character cuz I died I got this
is true right okay but Andy Ruiz is a
fighter
she has through all the skills to win
right he has none of the discipline yes
yes what you saw with Joshua is you sort
of discipline you right without the
skills yes right so he's total he's a
statue istic man only six foot six he
has a reach he has the right hand all
you got to say the hell out of it out of
the way of the usual reach and win
that's all he's out the Bordelaise a
shout out to Ruiz try to get the bag for
a third fight no and and I want to
address that I want to address the fact
that you don't deserve a third fight
you don't deserve a third fight because
your opportunity was there to shut the
door on this man
yeah every time he landed flush you know
a little boogie woogie mm-hmm you know I
always told you Joshua chin is not the
chin of a champion you know and he was
surviving off of his stature and off of
right Mitch matchmaking by Eddie Hearn
if he fights if any one of those to
fight Deontay Wilder he's going to crack
their skull literally they're going to
the hospital at the end of the night and
that's gonna happen alright so now that
we passed that I'm gonna talk about
something that happened recently this
week on Twitter to it now I'm gonna talk
to you about these guys that's right
here in this room right these guys in
this room with me um virtually um my
family now this family extends to
Channel five will that there's something
totally different but iron Lords is off
of channel 5 this is the group channel 5
is the team now we survived through love
and respect and what I've seen this week
is I saw a lot of love but I saw a lot
of disrespect
somebody said last week that I
disrespected a young female by the name
of PMS Jordan right um and I didn't I
called a fraud mmm all right now didn't
our name I didn't know on the English
circumstance it was a topic that Cognito
brought up correct and I called off
fraud for one to Microsoft to jump out
the window and he didn't have VR right
and they needed VR didn't mean VR now so
my comments on that was of such it was
it's not my job to go and search
somebody out and research them the only
research prey okay he's not prey so she
posted on Twitter no before you call
somebody a fraud you know do some
research on me right and she posted her
stats she showed her VR so me and her
bonded off the fact that I'm a VR due to
and I did then we talk back and forth we
follow each other it's mutual respect
and so people saying that it was
disrespect there was no disrespect that
she didn't feel that it's disrespect you
know I said definitely respect on
everything that you have and how you
support
she wants her counsel of choice to have
VR yeah me too not at this point in time
because it's not necessary in
Microsoft's plan we you know they
scraped any scratch to get back to
respectability you got back to the big
one funny but just not necessarily the
priority right now right a priority
right now the first party we're gonna
get that I don't want it just pointing
that out
greatest video in the world and y'all
guys gonna see that yes um alright so in
in atrium you had a portal rock yes now
I gotta give you one caveat then I think
was the night before I was talking to
kognito about portal rock and about
linking up with him and having them come
out with us you know while we in
California or whatever I'm gonna drink
with a guy talking to God because I
actually
respect to God mm-hmm right and then
I've been on the UH my show with him
before and we were very cordial with
each other there's absolutely no problem
people really think people be having
beef on plastic so he made a comment on
her topic so me and him go at it on
Twitter yes we go we went at it
respectfully if you look at any of the
tweets it's respect
and what Cognito had told me the night
before which I didn't know is that he's
a marine now let me tell you something
anybody that gives service to our
country
has the utmost respect from me anybody
that puts his self his his body his self
on the line he is a hero to me
okay so he's over there being a hero for
everybody here he's allowing you to play
video games this is the honest-to-god
truth because without our men and
service and men and women in service we
do not live the lifestyle that we live
respect all right
so he knows that me and him have mutual
respect to each other now we we were
joking around we jump online right to
play we're gonna play Street Fighter and
I haven't bolded up my PlayStation and
so long that I had a fifty gig down good
shooter but he had one as well so we had
a chat room talking long behold he's a
dude from the Bronx so like a lot of
comments a lot of comments that he said
you know he was you know from New York
New York so we we bonding and when we
laughing with joke and we're talking
about all the frauds on Twitter
defending each one of us and he said yo
he said you know what I never get any of
this response the way that I'm getting
it you know when I when I beef with you
I said you know why we are the vocal a
minority for our majority mm-hmm right
so we are the ones that's taken the dead
that then they're hit first you know so
Christopher Hart jumps in each other
kind of but it's respect what what some
guys did and what I saw you guys doing
is I don't care how you feel about
somebody on Twitter right
engage with them respectfully especially
if you follow me if you if you follow me
do not curse at this man do not call
this man outside his name I saw a lot of
you guys are disrespecting women um you
treat those women the same way you treat
your mother your sister whatever woman
that's inside your life that you have a
high regard for you treat her in the
same manner okay if you cannot engage
responsibly just shut up and just tune
out that I'm with that guy's gonna jump
it real quick on there yeah I saw the
adventure that was going on back and
forth so sad for the rocket y'all y'all
is going out but at the end of the day
like I said what most people don't know
is the conversation you guys had in
party chat you know I'm saying they just
blocking it out and building and that's
what it's about so at the end of the day
you know here's the thing
you know I'm saying we're gonna say
things that people are going to disagree
with we are not going the Lords are not
going to please everyone it's gonna be
hot takes that we have that people gonna
disagree with it but all we asked I
think king of trying to quit is that
let's be respectful let's not call
nobody out their name let's not do
anything that you wouldn't do in the
physical presence of that person you
know I'm saying because again we're not
into the keyboard stuff the Lord's and
outside in these shows we go to these
events and I'm saying and we're very
respectful that's all we ask you could
disagree you could say Carl I don't
believe anything is BS you know they're
all good you know saying but again once
it's calling somebody out they named it
disrespect we can't play that so yeah
then we have to remove you from the
premises we got a rabbit yeah we don't
we gotta move on um but you know for you
guys don't think I place which of course
we have the lord of the cooperative
experience and the gaming ninja himself
the shinobi lore Cognito
spreading that Romina Romina IOP not
telling you what you want to hear but
you need to hear for me it's been a lot
of the outer worlds member really
getting into a shout out to Provence he
I love that character she's she's one of
my favorite NPCs in the outer worlds bad
love I was upset I wanted to date her
yeah coming back play-doh but I picked
up the narcos on sale oh yeah bro first
of all it's the Netflix series which I
love you know there and it's XCOM style
hey go get twenty bucks for that Black
Friday sales that's what I did pretty
much it for me but now that we've gotten
all the particulars out the way what the
Lords have been planned I want to start
with Lord flannel fox his video system
history his journey to twitch and
YouTube and of course what led him to
creating the amazing flannel Fox YouTube
channel so Lord Fox let's start from the
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming first video game system
was the NES and Super Mario Brothers oh
the original NES okay okay daddy duck
hunt combo the Rob won the plane I
didn't have the combo I had Super Mario
Brothers - I had Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles mm-hmm which I barely remember I
did yeah
what's it it was thing I was bad that's
what I do at a young age that they a lot
of those consoles couldn't do our cable
and then I mean one I had a gameboy
which I'm a huge handheld gaming fan
even right now that's which was my
favorite console because you can just
play it anywhere you know what I'm
saying like I even I bought a gaming PC
thinking like all right I'm gonna took
this on the train that's right the
witcher 3 and then I'm sitting there on
the train with a lab
that's running hot roller like this
works but I look like the guy next to me
hates my guts but now I had the original
NES I had the Gameboy um the the biggest
impact on me as a kid as gamer was
probably the n64
um and the I got it like a week before
my birthday and I was like so excited to
play the ocarina of time mm-hmm so I
lied to my mom I was young at the time
and I was like mom I have no homework
tonight I can play the game play in 64
all night so I woke up the next morning
at 5 a.m. to do my history homework and
she opens the door to see if I'm awake
and she caught me in a lie we rounded
for a week so I just had the n64 sitting
there looking at me and I couldn't so I
was like not even ten like pain it was
brutal but then I woke up the morning of
my birthday like a three a.m. and just
played ocarina of time oh my god that
game was amazing but then you know yeah
I had the Gameboy for a Wild Game Boy
Color fell in love with Pokemon and then
grew up college I had no gaming systems
during college because I needed to do
college if I had that in my dorm I would
just feel like not doing my projects and
then I came back to Xbox 360 with Mass
Effect 2 and call of duty modern warfare
4 and I was like damn like I got so
hooked on modern warfare 4 I'm the
respawn joint right there I remember
that whoa what's it that's original and
I mean it was when they were Infinity
Ward for my understanding yeah well ok
yeah so but if that was their birth
before they had the the beef with
Activision and then separated and then
Vince impelling those guys creatively
spawn years later when I last see the
one that you like that's the one I like
and those are like my favorite Call of
Duty's those are made by those guys who
the original they were infinity war
which is now the original aw gotcha
after that I did love a black op stuff I
really liked because it was so rkt and
it was awesome like
gun game on black ops was my jam for
like the longest time I so graduate
college moved up to Brooklyn lived in
Brooklyn for like seven years just
recently moved out of Brooklyn but while
I was there I met my now wife and we had
a little dude and just I was gaming on a
Vita danam which came out what so like
we're used to going out every night and
I'm just at home now every single night
and I'm like man I got to do something
dude so I'm like I'm reviewing games now
that is what I'm doing I'm just like
that is my new life so like every single
night I was capturing game footage
playing on my subway ride to work and
using my to she game show host voice and
then yeah you know the switch well while
I'm sure that you gentlemen know this
the the YouTube community as far as
other creators are really kind and
amazing you know the audience can be
about as smooth as sandpaper sometimes
mmm that's one of those things that you
yeah you got it mr. super chest shout
out to Jeff singer our Savior saint-14
all hail Titan master race yes we
understand we get you bushes but all
right so I want to go back a second so
one thing you said that I really
appreciate that actually a lot of the
guests that we have in the realm is that
you are a huge handheld fan right so
you're gonna focus on that for a second
because I don't wanna get that I'm also
here if I wanted to speak to you that
like so you had Game Boy now did you
ever jump outside the game boy sphere or
was it you stuck in the Nintendo space
when it came to to the hands
I had a Sega Nomad believe that I
actually just remembered the name
because I remember jam in the Sega Nomad
when you put the the Genesis game go
there and I had Sonic and Knuckles with
the Sonic game on top like Radha T in my
yes way too many buttons do you don't
need all those buttons sonic fire man
yeah the six button it was a portable
jet-assisted shoutout to the batteries
that your family at first you just
support so happy actually I I don't know
why I gets hated on so much the PS Vita
to me whole special spot in my heart the
screen is beautiful yes the joysticks
are too small by the way I mean right
here lady
hell yes filled own mercenaries on the
PS Vita mmm-hmm first-person shooter
it's such a badass game I play very like
six times I mean I feel good I don't
have my switch with me it's downstairs I
feel like where's my child sorry you're
about to say so I'll just say about the
Vita man just like absolutely before the
switch I got absolutely does about one
of my favorite handheld just the form
factor and then they Venus still has
features that the switch don't even have
which is like party chat remember across
games and the trophy system integrated
with you know the PSN and stuff like
that and it was so ahead of time that
screen that beautiful oh Beautiful in
the corner games to I was a man who
Metal Gear acid just penetrate the
market like Nintendo pause so many on
there like that's where I played Super
Meat Boy that's why I played Fez that's
why I played um what's the roguelike
with the platformer where you're at
rogue legacy
like so many games that's where I got
introduced to the binding of issac
you have to it's so good well that's
right 3G but it wasn't like some weird
program King yeah it was a separate skew
like you had to buy it with the 3G and
it was uh I was upset I was upset that
that was the only one that was available
and I had to purchase that if I wanted
to give my veto and it was like I
remember going in the store so when are
you gonna get the other one they didn't
tell us about the allotment all we have
is one right here if you want the one
right here I can give it to you I think
I know that guy he works at my game they
had too much proprietary things rightly
they have like proprietary memory card
and there's all these things to try to
watch you - it was a nickel dime you in
today yeah they got me with that a
little bit ago cuz I was like oh it's my
little cousins 10th birthday I'm gonna
just pick him up Evita it'll be nothing
and then I got the Vita and then I
needed the memory card and all this
stuff and I was like it was like even
used with some games was like over 250
boxes 700 the system itself was like 5
and I got two of them actually I got
three of them but I don't think this is
the 3G one I think there are other ones
upstairs cause it has some it looked
better
um at least it looked better but after I
got that the memory calm and hit me in
the head with the memory card because
this thing cost so much money on the
floor another Sunday with the Lords 30 -
32 degrees Fahrenheit here in great
white north my 17 Wow old girl loves you
guys as well peace salute Wow - 32 I
don't want to know about that life of
damage that's brutal you are the king of
the north sir oh thank you
all the kingdom believed watch out for
the White Walkers back to Fox okay so
you had that video with one of your
favorites I did obviously we know you
had to eventually transition into that
switch so let's talk about that a little
bit oh man I was so excited I am it was
when my little homie was like three or
four months old that January where they
had that direct and I woke up at I
stayed up to watch it direct and then he
woke up at like 2:00 a.m. and I was like
well I'm pre-ordering this right now it
was like in January way as soon as they
announced them so i pre-ordered that and
breath of the wild and I'm trying to
think what else I got snake pass like
what's the goal it's like just to move
around
I'm not a collectathon fan in my games I
need more of objective based stuff but I
did like fall back in love with JRPGs
with a switch where I kind of like
really wasn't into them for the longest
time like I love Pokemon but then I
tried the this was still like early in
the switch's life where I was like why
are they and I tried the Disgaea 5 demo
and I was so I and the fact that like in
all demos need to do this your progress
carries over so I played the demo for
like three hours and I was like and this
carries over I was like I get to play
this on the trailer it was just so weird
- sorry no just real quick guys whatever
cuz Eggman is loving you right now cuz
he is a snake Paz fanboy and he said
it's the true spiritual successor
oh really yeah continue you would say
this guy you would transition that I
adore
khadijah no no it's fine I got to lean
into I was like I never kind of had a
opinion on anime and then I was just
like I'm leaning into it and I'm just
like since then I've just been like any
JRPG I could get my hands on or
turn-based games I was like I love
turn-based games are fantastic and the
tactical turn-based RPGs like into the
breach oh my gosh oh love that game but
true spiritual successor to banjo
kazooie look at me see it's not ukulele
okay then and who did that for you I got
my ukulele on cuz I saw one is in
Kickstarter really won't play the game
but I'm not money I really like that
company but I'm not and then they came
out money I gotta say that 3d camera I
was trying to play that on the train I
was like am I getting that headache just
just repeat that statement the 3d camera
on a platformer sucks yeah it's pretty
brutal yeah I think that's probably like
one of the worst ones is so egregious
like why didn't they use the mario
camera I didn't understand it it's very
intuitive that you're able to move the
camera around and it always puts you in
the best position the mario 64 camera i
thought um but this one it was just so
rudimentary like always behind something
and i'm just like i had to twist my
character around to fix it yes they had
that 3d mario 3d world and that was like
fantastic hold on phantom Fox
if you hooked on RPGs I hope you bought
that octopack travel I played about 16
hours I'm traveller
and now I was like I don't care what
happens to any of these characters
except for the hooker
now I was like what was good on a day
like you had some stories that were like
she's trying to avenge her father's
death
and then other ones that are like he's a
priest who doesn't know what he's doing
with his life I'm like we're really
varying interest here but like I'm not
gonna I got to the ground I was like I'm
moving on look as much as I hate to say
this bravery defaults away better game
then yeah then maybe false good-good
octopi Traveler idea I mean the art
style was great but I feel like most
people it's like yeah you know we got to
act too and that's where we stop you
know what it kind of reminded me of the
Wild Arms game where one of them you
spend like the first three or four hours
speaking about the individually and then
you do the story with them all together
yeah yeah sure
we got a $2.00 super chat from a dead
singer speaking for anime RPGs I'm
hooked on ff14 I had to stay away from
that because I felt myself getting too
addicted so I don't install that no
doubt no doubt back with the Fox beso to
JRPGs opens you up bad you just kept the
term base you just kept going and then I
was like so hungry at that time cuz I
was like I'm just you know working
towards a hundred subscribers a thousand
subscribers I was like I'm gonna review
any game that I can get my hands on and
please so many indie games that now I'm
just like perfect transition because
that's also to go into obviously your
channel you know saying a youtube
journey and stuff like that and um one
thing I noticed is like your reviews are
extremely meticulous extremely well done
and very concise and I did like thank
you yeah with that so what are you get
into that so again we know I know I've
heard about the legendary commute so is
that like the origin of the channel
because you're like I got all this time
to play games so let me just review them
like how did you say let me get into
YouTube
I want to do
I mean legit my real thing was like I
would love to work at IG Anna if I could
work it out that's why I do my reviews
like I don't do your typical like now
we're gonna talk about audio now we're
gonna talk about the graphics cuz some
games I'm like the audio is not worth
talking about I'm gonna talk about what
I want to talk about with this game and
that's what I like about i GN style
reviews they just you pick an opinion
and you talk about the things that
matter and I've been watching reviews
for like there's some times that I'll
watch a review ten times for a game that
I'm never gonna buy I just think it's a
really good review and I'm like I just
love everything that goes into a well
edited well-written review also once you
do it a couple times you just get into
the ritual of it and I have like I went
to school for animation I can video edit
I'm a designer now and I like I can
anything on the computer graphic wise I
was like I know I can do that and I got
a really good deal where I got a blue
snowball and an elgato for $60 on
Craigslist um yeah it was awesome so I
was like yeah let's give it a go and it
was just um so it until you go to print
company takes your kidney I do sit a
little goofy but without that oh god oh
yeah and you know it's I've had moments
in my life where I moved out of Brooklyn
and I bought a home and I took like a
little pause and the reviews and like I
actually not to get too serious but I am
an alcoholic and I quit drinking last
April and it's been like a journey kind
of Excel fugget my stress in order and
that's kind of when I started my Cigar
which I'll because I was like I need
something I can do with my friends
instead of like going cuz all my friends
drink and I'm like I need something so I
was like I'm gonna try smoking two
cigars see what that's all about so
honestly I've been the cigar disguised
Chado was bored which I saw yes a little
Instagram I'm pretty into my Instagram
right now with cigar
with two zeros and there's just it's
really it's funny too because people
that I follow that do pipe and cigar
content also play games it's just like a
nerd thing because there's so much to
learn about but um started smoking
cigars and I started smoking about a
month ago um pipe mm-hmm and it's
amazing it's super into that just
insulated my a little milk shed in my
backyard but I just zone out and listen
to video game podcast on my shed and
really it's like my meditation it's like
an hour and a half to smoke a pipe so by
the time you're done you're just like I
am centered I got your video game
podcast what are you a podcaster choice'
I love game scoop school that's I love
the first video game podcast that I ever
listened to was the vault
IGN by Jerry Petty is it's a fall out
podcast I loved it I actually will still
go back sometimes and listen to those
episodes mm-hmm I'm Jared Petty's an
interesting character and then one that
I got two from there um yeah you know a
Nintendo voice chat got a keep up on my
all my stuff like that and then I got um
I've been deep diving on a pipe podcast
I I wasn't I'm a huge Greg Miller fan
too but I will go like a month or two on
of kind of funny games daily and then a
month or two off okay cuz you just feel
like you need a break and then I get
back into it I'm like alright Greg tell
me what's going on every day Jodee with
the channel and all that stuff so just
for the record cuz I know like I said
you you said you're taking a break on a
personal side fun reviews well the
reviews ever come back alright now you
kind of just fill in things out until
life gives an order oh they'll come back
I'm working on a review right now what
I'm gonna do is just like I need to sort
of put it at my own pace and I'm not
gonna I'm only gonna review games that I
actually want to play not based on what
codes I get which is like things like
that and like for example me moving slow
right now I have recorded so much
footage of The Legend of Bumbo so I'm
definitely going to do a review on that
game
and then I'm just waiting to you know
get back into the summertime so it's
kind of slow on switch
honestly mm-hmm but just waiting to get
back into it maybe after the holiday
season when it gets too cold to do
anything else
hopefully it doesn't get to negative 32
over there on the journey and the
spin-off Channel
definitely appreciate the kind of guess
the Lawson although for introduce me to
your context that was really really cool
so uh also I know you hit the shows
would you be doing that again as well
hitting up there all right so I just
looked up his legend of bumble this is
you know is that okay so stream gives it
a nine out of ten 72 the circle PC gamer
but I'm looking at the pitches of legend
above all there's a lot of there is a
lot of detail because I I need to get
that Isaac and this can poop game little
egg you definitely gotta get checked out
so in the game the poop is block it
blocks you so if you set poop up and
friend you of the enemy attacks who
blocks you and P gives you an extra my
[Laughter]
you brought up the shows I am made the
biggest mistake last year to not apply
for a content creator pass because I was
like oh yeah you know you it's got to be
like 50k subs or something like that and
I think at the time I was like 3.5 K
subs and I was like I got there and I
saw guys with content creator passes
that had like a K subs and I was like
hmm I could have the yellow pass and I
could super drop the ball on our this
year for PAX East as soon as it gets
available I'm gonna submit for that and
I actually I got a pastor back some
blood oh is it
yes
vemana coming in hot I'll put the foot
covered hot it's a bailar we'll see ya I
also I have like Boston is my favorite
City
I just love crab legs and cities by the
water so that's what and King you'll be
able to still eat crab legs shellfish so
we will definitely get there we're
definitely I got a nice little pub
that's over there that gives you a bib
when he brings out the the lobster in
the crab legs so you miss your stuff up
I gotta say I go big free because I'm a
pretty I'm a pro at the crab legs I got
a real good little method you know I
always get the full lump all the guests
in the realm now here's the I already
know what one of these is going to be
I'm gonna ask your top five video games
or franchises of all time
oh okay any well yeah you know one no
already don't let's go
The Binding of Isaac number one my
franchises Assassin's Creed I skipped
college the day when the first one came
out and loved playing it I love how its
involved Assassin's Creed Odyssey is
fantastic
obviously Zelda I gotta go Zelda it's
super super impact I got I got a slow
you one zeldo we have to ask a very
controversial questions elder here is
very contentious here in the realm now
okay right you know yet what switch out
is the best time to undisputedly breath
of the wild
I gotta hear up your buddies everybody
sides on this one because I just love
these couple says you agree with me I go
first so here they're coming in hot
that's right head Tony that's right I
told you at least you put the coming in
hot right now
Zelda breath of the wild is covered a
high so here's the deal again for me
personally what's the worst what's the
worst you got wait you know it's mama
miss me and Fox bonding session right
now so you got a chill so here's the big
like for me the 3d transition right then
actually evolving right and then you
couple that with to launch a console
with that level of quality of game
you're not saying I remember I gotta say
the strongest thing for me for that game
was not the e3 trailer it was the review
by Jose Otero joinging salut Jose das a
Bronx brother right there salute oh yeah
I'm a big big big pond fan - no but yeah
I remember just like that it was morning
at work which I should have been working
but I was like watching that review
because it came out and I'd like later
that day my switch was getting delivered
so I was just watching the review for
like breath of the wild and you know
that tingly sensation that you get in
your brain when you watch something
that's just so amazing oh my god I got
asked King a question why are you
putting fraud alerts to the chat no way
no other Zelda but there brother
[Music]
okay did you did you beep
my massive sword that day the Master
Sword is neither here nor there if he
beat it or not is the fact that he did
put it into play because he was you know
playing it all the time it doesn't
matter if he go to their schools what is
the soda that you don't like the least
that you don't like I don't like you
like the least I think that's the same
question is what's your favorite that
you don't like the least honestly while
I didn't play this but I bet it would be
favorite the one that you play probably
honestly Link's Awakening and that's not
a bad thing we're talking about like out
of all the supermodels which one is the
ugliest just want to point out that the
flannel Fox
he's comparing all these supermodels
because he wants a man to give an
opinion on something he's never played
the worst one was the fact that he would
he would even like Gander a thought that
I don't play this but I'm assuming so
much rumor on podcast that Skyward Sword
is that's my thing you know that's the
only one that I've heard was bad but I
can guarantee you this if he plays that
game before we get the packs he's gonna
give me a handshake and a little homie
loves that game if you play that game
before you go to pax he's like man ki
made me waste so much time that you like
is wack is my bezel the game for the
simple fact this is the only Zelda game
that allowed you to actually weld the
sword right yeah it was fun that's the
only reason I never played it cuz I
didn't have a we had a we that actually
got a chance to play the game
no one says after they played it once
once once Dan but I know lady
everyone in IGN's you would have if you
would have two rooms of people that like
the game and not like the game would be
everyone in one room and then you and
that dude that was a moment so let's go
all right so um did you get your Zelda
off you so mines all created of time
okay love it missed Alger Hiss hell you
know what I'm saying like princess and
like majora's mask are all in the same
level but I do like ocarina more I need
to play Majora's Mask and I haven't and
I know it's on three TS
yeah alright so we got lost over
sovereign just I can just link to the
past that's the real answer is linking
[Laughter]
all I have to say is this out of
conversations only gonna go for you like
one every what you like I like sleepy
goblin says or Fox how you feel about a
Wind Waker amazing I never played
winwaker what I would love to play it
zoda's are the only games that I don't
care how many time the tittle remakes
I'm well right let's get it I wanted to
comment on switch we get a HD remake you
know we're not on the Wii U what's um
what's a Wii U on the switch it can
actually work because you have the
little nunchuck thingies
so definitely work pretty good no doubt
so we got binding of issac assassin's
creed zelda franchise right fallout
Fallout fallout 4 was like the game that
was
man loves you oh yeah I liked you too
yeah I play three and I played a bit of
New Vegas but I didn't play much like as
he played a bit and again it's cuz at
the time when I tried to play 3 and new
Vegas I was really into Call of Duty's
and I jumped in there and I was like man
these FPS mechanics feel so subpar and I
didn't I wasn't ready to appreciate them
for what they were at that time again
this is a great opportunity yes is this
I've already waiting to play the outer
worlds on when it comes down 2020 yes
sir I've always said fallout 4 is a good
first person RPG like light RPG but it's
not you could follow up I mean but it's
amazing it's an amazing Skyrim game then
or Elder Scrolls and I guess that would
have to be now that can't be my last one
you can't do this thing game oh dude
slay the spire is like one of my
favorite games I don't know if it's all
time but let's just go with that that's
the problem I gave him a year for the
deer yeah come back I'm hold you to it
you could always her unique was the
person freed was the first time we heard
cuz I won't be able to enjoy it if I
don't tell about that commute yeah man
two and a half hours each way south meet
in New York City man I got a lot of time
on that train kid he Jersey he golfs
work remotely this is out of hand now I
can't work remotely I manage manage
people but I will show Fox X cloud that
you might need to look into that explore
you know foot it for that ride okay I'm
down if it works body service on New
Jersey Transit though
he'll New Jersey in generalists I mean
New Jersey Transit in general is pretty
spot here we go move on you know Santa's
get into the show last week's poll
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question with Phil
Spencer's recent comments regarding VR
where project Scarlett be more of an
appealing purchase to you if VR was more
of an investment by Xbox the winner of
the three-way aisle people with a
commanding 71 percent of the vote is
nobody is asking for V baggers please
know at second place with only 17% of
the vote was they yes provide your base
options don't bat track on VR and in
last place and only 8% was I don't care
the real player in these VR streets is
Nintendo Lambeau V are in the poll Lord
King is this your victory lap sir would
you like to count nobody is screaming VR
now I'm everybody to understand like you
know I got a chance to see everybody's
collection that was a beautiful thing
for people to show their fandom a
low-key think I've seen more on lava
than I have VR like on the real like but
what I do understand is where you game
in why you gain there right and don't
ripple a bang is is exactly what we are
needing and want you know that there's a
fan base that is craving that and I'm
pretty sure that you know Phil Dominus
Maximus Spencer heard the cries of VR
now but he also heard the cries of
triple a bang his louder feed the hungry
of babies first
mm-hmm he's gonna get down to feeding
those little VR babies later into these
tablets got a lot of juicy ones to
discuss so I'm a building your could
tell a friend of the realm over the NPD
group we've had in the realm before
based on the switches Black Friday
performance he said they pushed 830
case which unit sold that last week so
they this could push the switch to
breaking the all-time November sales
record for hard so which is insane so
we're going to talk about that and then
I'll shout the game of Sutra they said
now what the previous record-holder is
the week he said according to the NPD
groups data to point to bump all over it
over two million Nintendo Wii consoles
were sold during the four we tracking
period ending in November of 2008 so no
platform in history has ever sold as
many systems in November as the we did
that year so right now just based off of
the
830 K that was sold for the switch for
one week yard and November as the Black
Friday week this record could be
threatened so I want to bring this to
the round we got the facts in the
building with this news you know I'm
saying like do you think this could
limit coverage but do we think that the
tender switch can break this record
that's the first question I've been
given to you and then if it does break
this record box is the switch the
Nintendo platform of all time let's get
I hope that it does break the record
mm-hmm because I think proving that
handheld I think it's good for handheld
gamers I think again I would also and
this is a little bit of a digression but
it's in this world I would love to see
another PS Vita so if they see success
from this I mean like the switch is a
huge success but I can't imagine that
people at Sony are sitting there like we
want nothing to do with her and held
gaming you know what I mean like it's
making so much money I slaughtered they
don't want to they don't want to go
Ryan it won't be it definitely won't be
its own platform but did you see the
package of controllers you know what I
would like for them I think what it is
is handheld successful for Nintendo but
handhelds are not successful for some
but I think Sony can actually do one
right if we all listen to me sony Sony
listen to me what I want y'all to do is
I want y'all to scrap your PlayStation 5
ideas right scrappy scrappy right and I
want y'all to put out uh something that
looked just like the switch less
powerful 720 screen wack controllers and
I want I want y'all to fall in the
bucket I wanna show I want y'all to fall
for the banana pipe in there banana in
the tailpipe I want you to fall off the
edge with that and then as far as
greatest of all time as it goes now I
think only time will tell you know
because as of before that I wouldn't
even call the we the greatest Nintendo
system of all time I'd probably say it's
the SNES because it's continued to hold
up over so many years but for me
absolutely okay I mean it's oh it's so
good
just like and I would be curious with
those numbers to see how many of them
were like og switches compared to the
switch light because I'd be curious to
see like is the is Pokemon pushing the
switch light sales so people are doing
that and only playing handheld because
you know taking a break from reviews I
really got to experience the switch
again with The Witcher 3 waking up in
the morning before work playing it on my
television and then get into a good
spots where I can just jam on someone's
on the train like oh and this is just
having that simple thing it's just so
fantastic so Fox you are the epitome of
the Nintendo switch trailer commercial
with it launch the guy that had it in
his house and then he's like taking it
and he's like going or they could watch
the only things you better not be on the
roof of the club without party
you better be that guy you don't be the
guide to basketball court oh yeah I did
break off the joy Kahn's at PAX East cuz
I was trying to I was like all right I'm
talking to as many people as I can
I got like 500 business cards so I'm
heading out to everybody but I did break
it break off the joy cons and play a
Mario Kart with some random guy swish it
was just like the commercial and it
sucked you need to play this in your
hand like I don't know it was one joke
on turn sideways yeah it's a little
rough
that's where the Fox is it let's bring
it to the switc loving attic let's bring
it in do you think would that the switch
could break this record of the week and
if it does at it is to switch the coke
the Tendo platform
I think it's gonna break the way and I
think it's probably gonna beat the
PlayStation 2 so now I think it's gonna
outsell the ps4 in its lifecycle Wow I
think when the PS 5 comes out it sells
gonna drop dramatically and switches
still gonna be there so mmm interesting
I mean one like two months last year
it's like double what the other
platforms so money song can you get that
super Chester hold on one second okay
super Jeff I'm a dizzy thank you sir
got the Pokemon switch light with sword
tired of fighting my son for the switch
switch brethren we did I mean it's funny
because when you talk about why those
numbers are so high I think it's the two
SKUs I think the light really it's it's
almost there at that sort of like
impulse buy price point looking at
Nintendo's commercials if they
some type of mind trancing to people if
they're doing some type of hypnosis on
these people because this is out of
control things I mean it again once they
gave you a $200 price point on that and
I said I still think 200 was a little
high yeah but you get that impulse buy
150 which will be there at some point
probably sometime next year
totally um it's just they're just gonna
keep selling like hotcakes in that
that's what they're banking it they're
banking on that putting them at the
checkout counter as you're walking out
like grab it grab some gum grab a switch
like you don't really know I know this
though I know when I went to go pick up
my son's Xbox one and I'm at Best Buy
you know pay for it overnight so I'm
coming and they have all the online
orders and that's part right and I'm
looking at County that's it you know I
was gonna take a picture I said but
that's a little bit too much no but I
counted there were seven Playstations
you know fours there I don't know
various degrees of probably a pro or
whatever and it was seven um Xboxes
there it was one VR headset in like a
couple of lis controllers right and then
there was like 30 to 40 min Tyndall
switches mm-hmm and I said my god these
guys are killing Black Friday now here's
the only caveat in the whole
conversation is they were not hey I was
just about to say 10 you literally stole
my next point yeah these guys are
selling at full price and people are
walking out the store like they got a
deal that's you're getting your best
you're getting is a $25 gift card right
and then a lot of those are still that
old SKU with the with the battery yeah
didn't they bundle some of them with
Mario Cart yeah and it was the old one
with Mario Cart not the new worn that
exactly solve like the
thing about it for solid fox is that
this they get it they low-key getting
rid of the older skew that doesn't have
the extended battery elaborate like
that's the funny part
it's literally almost like a removal a
being of stock and it's the same deal
you had last year
listen you can go by we you right now
brand-new box 500 you just either copper
gold that's it civil of those first
parties man they'll still pay full price
for these games it's crazy
no doubt so solve math so here's a 30 K
for one week you know saying we got it
we got the whole buff due to round up
this numbers to see if they can beat the
to Milly rock shout the boss move see if
they Millie rock so K if they do it is
it the cold I mean I think sales wise
yeah but go but should go a minnow black
it's the SNES man it's just I mean just
maybe it's nostalgia but it is I feel
like it's the SNES - mine's a n64 mm I
don't know why man that's where Super
Smash Brothers originated for me Pokemon
none of you guys mentioned the actual
record holder which is the week like
we're where we at with the we like the
way was hot garbage you don't respect
his opinion on garbage alone we're gonna
have to give you the name oh brother
it might be this might be the one that
knocks everybody out because we're still
in the middle of the lifecycle
you know be honest which I really think
it's just started hitting it's tried to
be on
oh I know I said that there's a good
chance that it ourselves the PlayStation
because this is sells without us without
a cell like I imagine when you know the
PS 5 and the next Xbox shops they're
gonna try to compete to that to a point
so much my question is right
when does Nintendo see because they
don't even feel they have to you know to
come to Black Friday which is probably
they turned it into one of the biggest
shopping days of the of the year right
to come to Black Friday and you
steadfastly safe I'm not lowering my
price for no one why are you leave and
they're still selling in record numbers
means that they're justified in they
stamps and they don't have to budge for
no one so you can drop those new systems
all you want they still not gonna be
cheaper than a switch at the current
price so I just looked up an interesting
little stat because when I was hearing
you talk about like King I believe you
said it like it's still in the middle of
its lifecycle or just hitting its stride
I was like you know what when did the
original 3ds drop because that until you
still drop in 2011 Mme it came out and
that's so that's eight years the 3ds
selling like fire and it's nowhere close
to as good as the switch so I have like
a even addict that I believe said like
gonna beat out the ps2 like maybe if it
can take like an eight year um sorry
cool life cycle cuz like the 2d s is
still hot now I'm still moving I guess
the question I guess I throw it back to
you Fox's do you think now obviously
we've had this like I've heard the
counter-argument what people say look
people already have an Xbox and
PlayStation and they feel that you know
the the switches did default secondary
console now my question to you Fox is
now 2020 we know the next-generation
consoles are coming in this project
scarlet the you know the PS 5 do you
think at launch of those consoles that's
when the momentum finally slows down or
absolutely none
because that's when breath of the wild
twos gonna come up and everybody's gonna
be like whoa there's another Zelda even
guys that don't give a sh no no and
honestly I own every I have a gaming PC
I have a ps4 have an Xbox one I don't
give a damn about teraflops I already
have a PC who's gonna get a ps5 like I
can't play that on the train okay so the
portability fact ability it's it's
everything if you're gonna get a game
that is not the highest end graphics or
first party and you're not playing it on
the switch you're making a mistake
oh well shout the EAD I listen to you I
mean they have to but here's the what
about I understand your point no
graphical fidelity but what about
obviously there's going to be a
disparity where I graphically what he
starts come on do you think at the very
minimum though at least Nintendo should
at least start planning that suppose it
pro version of the switch where they
have a look so the leap is not as
substantial I mean I would love if they
did I buy the pro day one but then you
got a look at her you don't think so
honestly look at the difference now V
they they have which already get 540
people still eat that up of a man is to
get it on there
managing to get it on there's and even
an option later on I don't think I don't
even think they attempt the new games I
think they go the whole we're out and
start doing a whole bunch of independent
different games games that show their
strengths and their strength alone that
you can only get on this platform
sebring now they're giving you these
these other Triple A games that
everybody played in some space right and
they finally found out how to make it
work on their platform right now that
you got the switcher on their platform
some people only way of consumption was
through the switch so they never get a
chance to see that higher fidelity and
you don't
if you look at it from sales standpoint
Pokemon looks like it's about the L out
so all its competition so I mean every
game they've sold has been selling
extremely well very interesting to see
like I said we weren't there on a
precipice of possible history um yeah I
was shocked to be honest it was doing
they had that kind of a Black Friday
sales with no little crystal balls and
it's it Tennessee now we have them
listen to you a listen I'm bending the
knee I don't care what you say I don't
need you is gonna sell well but honestly
when I saw that PlayStation package I
said wow okay I don't know about this
it's cuz a Pokemon told you I don't know
way back way but when they announced the
Pokemon that that month that whenever
that Pokemon comes out Nintendo is going
to murder the competition he said it and
then I was like hey that's the one I'm
gonna get then nobody got but uh uh uh
uh I got oh you got it okay it's always
talk but the fact that I had it already
predicted he told you what was going to
happen and then I'm seeing like the
sales people talking about this thing
I'm willing to bet if you go back and
look in history there's been very few
times Pokemon has at one dmpd and the
corrective platform it was on right now
hold on what's like a Bradley too chatty
talking best to me right there
so basically shout the stitch in color
cog he was like um the switch is gonna
be great in that cloud this is actually
response to stitches point that he feels
that when X cloud comes on the scene
fully launched that data is going to be
a threat because of the portability I
even had a commercial with Trevor Noah
just recently he's like he's raving
about X cloud right now to port X club
don't have a Pokemon well it here's the
other thing too we got also fact as much
as I'm I'm here
you know the thing is the switch to will
have the advantage if I jump on a plane
or I'm Fox right and I don't I'm not a
train if I don't have a strong signal
I'm gonna move then X cloud is useless
to me right
so the advantage to switching to has is
in those places where you don't which
and not to mention X cloud you know
there's a lot of places but for the most
part you know you can pipe you got a kid
you could buy switch you know not to
worry about any kind of plan so make
sure they could play that you just buy
that give it to them you gotta think
about the rest of the country like we're
blessed to be around like a metropolitan
area around New York City but like
people in Kansas they don't have good
internet you know like there's terrible
internet all over the country but you
can still play your Pokemon this right
the X cloud is not a replacement that X
cloud is an option yes correct
the switch is a dedicated machine max
all right so it is dedicated to do its
function and it will always do that
function better than any streaming
device or anything that you get to
actually to $2 superjet here is cash for
addicts tears you are the brother
the button by mistake twice now we like
that keep doing that I want everybody
the stream team lead guy packs easy you
know we'll see you again but real
quickly finish that we move on arm look
at the end of the day you know I know
King nothing believe he came thinks I'm
lying
I am definitely shocked like this is
something I do not think this like you
thinking happen at the end of the day
for me y'all know the history I was shot
internal broken I was want to show
recently and um as a Sega kid growing up
it was the enemy you know say it for me
that's like old school fanboys so like
my always thing with them is yes they
had the first party they had the bangers
and stuff like that but it was always a
little too over the top kitty for me
then it was like you didn't get the
third party stop so dad always kept me
from fully investing in the Nintendo
ecosystem I had them eventually but I
just would never become you over the top
because of those two factors so at the
end like what the we've not even counted
me to me up no disrespect but it felt
gimmicky that's like you bring your mom
over you bring you you know the family
over you you know you dust it off and
you bring that one movie boxing it's all
what it's sold but I almost didn't count
the Wii because it felt like something
else it felt like oh wait a second you
don't count the great a system no I'm
just saying for me I understand I
recognize the greatness
I remember the sales I was it was bad
for me so I was like okay cool were you
in the bushes I'm completely done with
Nintendo at that point solve you know
anytime don't talk to me about it
they do not exist until you don't exist
until they get mature titles and until
they get third party on board so when I
seen the switch literally like how foxes
describe him I saw that commercial and
I'm like yo that's me you know I'm
saying I'm at home you docked you take
it up I'm literally the guy that goes on
a plane with it like that's me all the
way so that was the nation showed you
Skyrim dead then I saw we're gonna get
to that
and I saw the Zelda and I'm like wow
that's a triple
that's compressive right so I'll never
forget I got a shout out to Attica in
this way so I'm still in the middle but
I'm excited actually
yo sounds a trailer did you see it and
I'm like you got to see you got to see
it over the iron and I can't front yo
that zelda trailer and he was climbing
the wall and the music and a joint and
I'm like oh this is gonna be a system
seller you know they're like me bows yes
yeah they got out of me probably two
thousand dollars because I brought my
switch and with every amiibo I put my
eyes pawn I got it and only reason is in
Zelda they gave you stuff mmm now I'm
sorry but that level of interactivity is
definitely high on my list the camera
button all the stuff the form factor it
again speaking the Fox I'm a Vita fan
but we got to admit the thing that
killed the Vita is they didn't have that
second and the law so now I got the
second analog I got the double shifts
right cuz that you got full
functionality like a console let's be
real that's the first time that a
handheld really kind of gave it up so
I'm like okay cool and then the last
factor for me was there a party support
finally you don't say you getting your
switches regardless at the resolution
you're there there's a ton of Nintendo
fans that are getting triple-a Bangerz
finally on the Nintendo but they're not
excluded anymore and then from the indie
standpoint solve it's an indie haven man
it is you're getting all the fly in
these yet a lot of times getting them
first and stuff like that so yo they had
a tremendous year man that to me is what
won them over
you know I'm very curious to see what's
gonna happen and then the last thing
I'll say is just that I think what
they've really done is they stepped
their marketing up because we've all
talked about the Nintendo
Rex and how Nintendo really knows how to
get their fanbase pumped you don't say
like you watching direct and one more
thing and you know it's something that
the bass really is excited about so yes
I think they I think switch is coming in
hat
you know I call you fraud oh and then
the reason why I'm gonna call you a
fraud is because you guys have predicted
this since this thing started with MPD's
we have not one NPD cents ever though
they definitely sparks the like
PlayStation arise they arm up and
Nintendo stomp on his shoulders it has
been a round-robin bundle switches when
an MPD since these two frauds you know
y'all forget we used to talk about MPD
so much yeah we got so sickened me and
Atticus so sick and tired of hearing
these two for those victory laps every
month as long as I can remember now
that's enough you have to see King in
the messenger chat anytime we're putting
in our topics and it's that time look I
didn't look at role my it's my man it's
the DJ no switch it's a defender system
for me this is the 40 when I connect it
it's the one it's the one that gets
everything right it did from the one
that did a lot wrong it did everything
right and it what is it focused on what
this strong is a Twitter's portal you
are not in color but he said let him
merely rock
you know you know what the funny thing
is King every month this man says it's
our moment this moment be over Lord
addict you've got the greatest greatest
thing so it's River you know that's the
same person that leaked the fact that we
could potentially that Deathstrike
potentially go to PC mm-hmm
so it turns out that he did okay first
off I want to point out that I've seen
this plenty of times people say he
didn't leak nothing he just reminded
people that was gonna PC mm-hmm
if I remember correctly even announced
the date was cut being announced
did he not that he is the Russian
youtuber yes yes so apparently he's
predicting that horizon zero dawn is
coming to PC and first off I want to say
horizons made off the same engine deaths
training is so it would make sense that
they were going to port one of their
games the PC it would be that game
because it'd be easier since the decimal
integer is already on PC at this point
you know being developed so what I want
to bring to the laws hey did you expect
this and B is what the kind of impact is
gonna have on Twitter it's see what's
gonna be happening next-gen that's the
impact on tonight's what attic was to
him i'ma say this right I told you guys
before y'all guys are not looking
familiar anymore and I what happened to
all the rhetoric where you know our
triple-a bangus named the bushes over
here
we don't let it out mm-hmm now you have
to diversify your portfolio right you
have a boss that's in line with my boss
and my boss is telling your boss
listen you don't understand remember
number two picture let's go back to the
picture of those three dudes on stage
right and we're gonna go back to Reggie
Reggie standing on his Square my man
Reggie fils-aime who said he will rather
die than to follow what this dude next
to me is talking about that's right
Reggie got out of here he said y'all
gonna put somebody else in there and
Bowser is down for the program so we got
Bowser in pocket right Bowser's complain
he's complicit everything that is going
on now he's complicit all right so all I
know is first picture could have
personally picked Bowser and be like
you're gonna get this man get this man
his shield and he got him a shield so
now mr. Laden is no longer with the
company
I'm just the weird circumstances this
new guy in charge he seems to be down
with everything we talking about me now
call it coincidence so just to clarify
King you're saying you're saying fill
Dominus Switzer is dictating everyone's
news on in the gaming industry master
chessmen move put your positions where
you have to move in a certain manner
it's not what they want to do come on
man it's what they have to do what they
have to do honey it's an old it's an old
IP all right fine you already made your
money Oh guys I'm not buying the game so
what do you care if somebody else enjoys
the game a lot a game to go someplace
also can have a second life what you
guys are trying to do is be selfish
trying to hoard everything here but
maybe you are selfish you're going to
die stagnated by yourself in the corner
if you let that game get out and that
game does super numbers on the PC
now what happens you have a different
fan base that might purchase into the
PlayStation ecosystem that might move
forward into it it comes out first on
the PlayStation then it goes the PC but
it's just FOMO and he can't wait
he's on a Playstation cuz the game's
first here looking at the logic going
forward but Phil's knows this knows ok
I'm gonna put game pass over here I
don't care where you play it as well as
you are engaging your company needs to
adopt this type of mentality that
because we're moving forward into
streaming do not get behind we have
plenty of things remember your Sony
Walkman remember your Sony disc players
yeah in the bushes right now because I
don't have a situation where you're
constrained usek properly and that was
your main focus of money so this is your
only pillar don't lose your last pillar
but I see it in great standing maybe you
know playing in a super high real 4k and
and actually see the game how it's
really intended to be that as we do it
because it's not true 4k but me being a
graphics [ __ ] that I am I would really
like to see the game in its full
fidelity but let me actually just get
before I pass it to foxes so I will say
you know there's plenty of room for
expansion with the millions of people on
Steam what one thing I did forget to
bring up is where you guys think this is
gonna go for those come before yes I
just gotta ask just one question we get
to if again rumour Rumour let's move but
my question King is the feedback to what
you're saying the counter to what people
are saying that you're saying is that
you know people feel that some people
feel that this is not good for gaming
and for Sony if if this is true that
horizon zero dawn goes to PC that this
is not good and that they shouldn't be
mirroring Xbox strategy what saying you
to that it will concern me if they
didn't do it it would concern me if they
saw the potential to make money and they
didn't it will concern me if they saw a
avenue of expansion and they chose to
block it off of
old ideologies this is not 1984 no more
guys this is not 1996 this is not
cartridge-based systems this is this is
this is not red vs. blue anymore
you guys saw stadia come out thank god
they stumbled because if they happen to
have hit right could you imagine what
next year would look like mmm alright so
yeah diversified portfolio why are you
caring if it comes out on pc you played
the game already now only person that
should be upset is the person that
didn't buy the game right because now
you're upset why there's no reason for
you to be upset that somebody else's get
a chance to eat the cookie you already
ate your cookie so let somebody else eat
cookies man everybody want cookies too
let's get the [ __ ] in here man Oh what
do you think about this potential rumor
again for the record rumor rumor rumor
of horizon zero dawn possibly come to PC
and again if it if it does happen to
addicts question you know which platform
do you think will be steam you think
might be the epic store if it does have
so Fox the floor is yours
man it'd be great for epic if it came to
that epic store mm-hmm and if it came to
PC in general I think it'd be great for
gaming I don't think it would be good
for her Sony in my personal opinion
because it's definitely not red vs. blue
but it is blue vers green mmm still hard
and I I get what you're saying that is
an old way of thinking King but it's
also that's what Sony has like Sony
doesn't have game pass like PS now is
not game pass
mm Sony's big core is their first party
titles like to push it even further like
God of War coming to PC like no never
never do it keep it on there it is like
yeah but I'm just saying keep it on a
Playstation platform
don't what about what about death dragon
- Dragon's on PC right now they've been
open in the door Detroit is or PC
there's a guy found their way I'm not a
true of the sale
exclusive that was entirely funded by
sewing yeah yeah I don't know I I don't
think it's a good move for them cuz I
just I just don't like that that would
be the only reason for me to ever buy a
Playstation like that's why I bought a
Playstation I hate PlayStation
controllers my knees table controller
like by far I don't know what about this
though what about uh I'll be what here's
the question for you what is stopping
you if it goes to PC why is that
stopping your personal enjoy that's my
question like why would that stop you
should be happy no no I totally the more
people that get to play it that's great
okay and I'm happy for it gorilla does
the horizon zero dawn right correct and
I love them because they made the
Killzone franchise which I loved on the
Vita they're a great company and it's
good that they can make more money but
for Sony I don't think they should do it
this is not like it we've talked about
this devil's advocate argument for a
while already I've done the thing about
some Sony and I I agree I'm happy if it
is the truth I'm happy that's going to
PC fantastic everything more people to
play this game especially on a high of
super high powered PC yes but that said
Microsoft has been pretty they've been
preparing their base for this reality
for a long time right
they've been preparing their base for
letting them know our first party stuff
is going to be fluid between Xbox and PC
and quite frankly we're trying to put it
on anything that can run it like anybody
there's gonna shake our hand and say yes
we're gonna try to do PlayStation has
been stead this little by little now has
been sort of creeping in and making
statements on it him before he went out
the door for me just just just your part
right that one more this is not the same
Sony it's not the same Sony but this is
the thing they haven't it's been it's
been a little comments here little
comments there
they have bowed and said we're all in
right so the base of the PlayStation for
whom that exclusive exclusivity stuff
matters it's still under the impression
that that's gonna be a core tenet of
their business moving forward that our
stuff is gonna stay here 100% right they
haven't come right out and said this is
what we're going to do and it
for it than what you're used to oh and
and and it goes back to the argument I
made a while back it says I think that's
the future right I think that's where
everybody needs to go where whether
services or whatever try to get your
stuff on every platform possible you're
gonna make more money period you are I
understand
creating an identity for your platform
with these with these exclusives but
it's the its identity it's not money if
you think about money the Smart Play is
to put it everywhere you can't write I
don't think they may not be again
Microsoft is prepared for this on every
level they've prepared their base and
they're ready for me at from from up
from a company standpoint they're ready
to engage in this future not how
absolutely ready PlayStation is to
actually engage in this future so you
were kind of grill fox in that in the
sense that you don't necessarily feel
they should change their identity that
they should stick to kind of what got
them to dominate the PlayStation 4
generation they're like this generation
I think if they they're not as well as
prepared as Microsoft to do that then oh
then don't jump I'll give you kick shot
to preach King hashtag iron all right
something the Christopher Hart right and
only reason I'm giving me the light
right now even though you don't put none
in chat I'm giving them the light is
because he's probably one of the only
people that follow uh that uh friend
requested me on PlayStation actually
jumped in a chat with me so shout out
salute to you now I just want to say
this right I don't see your game being
and everywhere it can be as devaluing
your game actually the more places and
the more eyes that get a chance to see
something that you have shows that you
value your property because you're
letting the world see it when you horde
something to yourself only you and those
chosen few right can see it now we've
already stated that we have weak
internet all over the world right and
this is the reason why I
believe that the switch is going to gain
further traction once against service
like game paths can be implemented on
that machine right is because the
Nintendo switch is going to hit every
corner of the world they're versatile
they understood they can win in a
certain manner and they switched it up
Sony is the only company out of these
big three that is playing steadfast into
the old tradition Nintendo Nintendo I am
so sorry but Nintendo is so old-school
you will never see a Nintendo game on PC
oh no you won't you know what I mean but
there's they are the hoarder like
PlayStation and plays way more ball than
Nintendo does in that aspect you're not
gonna see Nintendo eventually start
releasing some of their stuff on mobile
to be all tried that already
this is really nasty the mobile thing is
that that's that was their way of trying
to penetrate other money like that was
their way of doing it you I mean they
have we're gonna make tons of money I
made a lot of money they're not great
games but they made a lot of money a lot
of money I just don't I mean okay money
you lose them loss by hoarding their IPs
out of these next three people I mean
these three companies to Kings Point I
mean I'm saying they're in the business
of making money right so if if there's
money on the table let's just say
hypothetically
and they say for horizon zero dawn or
what-have-you right you really tell me
that like Sony because we all know that
right now for as up as a total
corporation it's really only the games
division that is kind of keeping them
afloat right now that is really
profitable that's really soaring right
so I just find it hard to believe I it's
a king's point that they would turn down
that situation if it was presented to
them especially now when you starting to
see baby steps Nintendo really hasn't
played ball on that level at all right
but we're seeing so nice look like
in there and then deaf streaming and
then you know I said obviously even the
services thing like you know Microsoft
has their first party day in date Sony
doesn't but we're starting to see
exclusives NPS now and I'm saying now so
it's like my question is you know to you
solve like you think they won't
eventually just say like going like all
the way with this thing just cuz I 100%
i 100% think it's the right move right
right it I just you have to stop and
think about how their base is going to
react to that the bottom line is the
bottom line is it's the right money move
it's the right business move absolutely
100 percent games are getting more and
more inspector expensive to make not
every game is selling spider-man numbers
not every game is selling that you want
to make as much money off of your
product and have the tail of your
product be as long as possible
hmm it makes business sense moving
forward right forget about I understand
boxes I respectfully disagree I don't I
understand I understand it Fox but at
some point hmm the green versus the
green versus blue it's gonna take a
backseat to what actually makes money
has the top-selling consoles like yes to
ps4
they have their exclusivity that's what
it is look at numbers if you look at the
10 million sold by spider-man right and
you know full well that by putting that
game on PC you're gonna sell another 7
million but a lot less Playstations if
you do that you think you think Fox your
argument is that they are still there I
don't focus on the cost of hardware
sales because here's the thing I want to
bring to you Fox a lot of us at the
roundtable and a lot of the analysts
have said you know because of what's
happening with the Google's the Amazons
that even though streaming might not be
ready right right right now right yeah
but let's say five years from now when
5g has penetrated the mark and all these
things eventually it will happen almost
similar like to the digital age like
maybe Xbox a little too aggressive
coming out to jump but eventually it did
happen we're very digital for the most
part right so the question is with
Sonne right in this situation you don't
see that eventually they may have to
evolve from just the pure console
hardware model if they can get more
sales another way and still keep their
business on you completely don't think
there's any tried-and-true to that
they'll have to evolve when it gets
there but even when you're talking about
a streaming service if you want to watch
the crown or chef's table you're
subscribing to Netflix that's not
available on anything else that's what
you're doing everybody has their
exclusives Apple has their own shows
Amazon has their own shows it's all
about the exclusivity like yes you can
watch that in multiple places and once
we get there as a generation I think
that's fine but for now they are leading
the game for a reason so at your case
you say if it's not broke don't fix it
however wait Jim Ryun in in pocket and
surely they've seen to switch
philosophies very quickly what a lot of
things early I'm just concerned with
that part because I've never seen them
kind of even think about adopting and
then he's making comments about yeah we
have to change our thing with you know
with the cloud and this is stuff that
you know we have to get into and yada
yadi I didn't obviously we know that's
just no way to digest their stuff we're
not saying like it's like I don't know
even at the same point like let's go to
something beside like port it to switch
yeah my thing is you know obviously the
room you know I'm going to crazy with
this yes and predicted their stranding
I'm awesome wait and see you know I'm
saying to be honest with you the only
thing that feel a little sauce is
February 2020 it will be out of control
once that happens because to me it's
like if you wanna do it it comes out in
February do you think if this is true
and it's come out in February do you
think we'll see it like an asset like
the video game awards of the state of
play that's about to come up
you know how when you go to the dock
then you're gonna go get a needle mm-hm
and then the doctor does this like he
puts like a little thing in a head for
you know cuz if you got a baby right you
know and he'd do something like that the
baby look at the needle a step yo y'all
right now looking at this and y'all
gonna find out all your games is gonna
be like when it comes down to it I
honestly think that it just does happen
right first off I think the Twitter's
gonna implode it's gonna explode it's
gonna implode in an exploit it's gonna
go how the sun's gonna go all right I
think people have stuck to their guns
for a long time and I don't know how
they're gonna be gonna react to this I
do think that if this happens it's
coming to the epic game store I think
epic game store has been getting you're
good relations with Sony and if they do
sound like a 10-year exclusivity don't
so need to sell their games on their
platform that will automatically force
people's hands cuz you you can say well
I ain't buy stated ação is say to decay
or something on another platform than C
bar you gonna say you ain't go play God
of War 2 on another platform I mean but
listen like I said my only question is
that they date that's the only they seem
suspect to me yeah you know I'm saying
because at the end of the day if you're
gonna do a move like that in my opinion
you need to set to me it's a promotional
tool to set up the sequel for horizon
zero dawn to write and horizon during
two of my knowledge is not coming out at
the top of the year so I mean I don't
know we'll see what happens all I will
say is that the only thing that leads a
little credence to it is obviously des
Tran and uses the decibel engine which
the same thing horizon zero dawn so it
has shown that it is you know portable
to that platform and I'm saying this
just Kojima Odette's Trey you're just so
neo destron a controller right I don't
think so not necessarily I think I don't
know what kind of bag they gave him but
they gave him bag they gave him gives
him control over pretty much everything
I don't really think I don't know if
it's a multiple game
anything like that but I think when it
comes so near interactive owns the
trademark assess the IP yeah they own
the trademark
yeah that's Wow anyway all I say is from
the decimal standpoint the engine we
know that it's proven portable because
of the DES trending on the PC so our are
saying it is in the realm of possibility
that's all I'm going this is what
happens we'll see if they drop the bag
I don't know I'm waiting see if we gonna
see what happened it's very interesting
because Twitter is go it's on fire
right now about this big possibly going
to feel out oh there's a very upset yet
people are doing that it would it would
it would undercut a potential remaster
for ps5 all of this stuff and it's like
ISO knees not really big on remasters
per se they're they're big on a
straight-up remake but a rematch like
anything that you've seen from like you
know when the Xbox Kinect came out and
they did you know they started doing
crazy stuff like nine times resolution
on all game up like that old Sony games
on PSN never really did any of that and
everything at that route like not even
you gotta you gotta think how many games
that Sony has published or they've paid
for it started coming to PC in the past
year already
right like you got all the Quantic Dream
game yeah dead stranded that's coming
their dreams will probably make his way
to PC at some point that will be
fantastic some late to the show salute
to the iron Lords panel but that's all I
got what a move more cuz we gotta get
flat through we got the watch thing so
uh solve
Lockhart's Batman is it bad we have not
used this terminology since e3 last year
we haven't used anaconda and Lockhart
for like from one survey and it's back
um so Jason's trial reported it this is
why everything was interesting about
this I don't think Strider just gonna
come out and record on something that
doesn't feel strongly about
so it was reported that uh Lockhart is
actually a real thing
mmm-hmm Xbox is a parent plan is to
release two SKUs of their next
generation hardware as we had you know a
thought about that for I guess the past
year and a half we assumed it was an
be to skews one called Lockhart the
other one codename anaconda and but at
eight last year's e3 this past year's e3
they codenamed everything scarlet
everything fell under the scarlet banner
and they seemed that Lockhart was dead
and it was once cute according to de
Chasseur eye on his SOI sources no that
is not the case
ah a lower-powered diskless x-box next
year next box to a codename Lockhart is
apparently in the works what do you guys
think of this you think it's real
based on the specs that have been talked
about what do you think about potential
price point and do you think they should
do it because we've had that discussion
as well do you think it should be
something that they do no doubt the Fox
is back what do you think about this
potential to skew approach vital Fox I
mean it would make sense they have the
xbox one sad Edition now and then they
have the regular so it seems like it
makes sense honestly what about price
point you think a price point what you
think would be the sweet spot for it
anything it's I think this could be you
know 399 for the disc list for the news
that's a lot that's a lot because I
think that I think the actual the other
one there and I think it's called the
Anaconda right yeah I think it's gonna
be a hundred to two hundred dollars more
so you're talking 600 and a god it could
be anywhere from five to six hundred
yeah yeah I think I think Lockhart's
going going to be like the outer gate
starting point I think they got to keep
it at 299 I put I doubt where I highly
doubt it mm-hmm that would be insane a
$2.99 console that we don't like unique
generation no think about it now like
the consoles our $2.99 yeah exam is a
couple years under development so play
no I know but you're just getting like I
don't know that's a really high price
point for the lower edition and I think
the reason it's gonna be that is because
I think PlayStation 4 is coming out of
500 okay so your prediction if you take
oh because place pi5 you think anacondas
six and I think they're gonna use a la
carte to uh uh to beat them at price
point they use it they're gonna use
anaconda to beat them with the power
miss Martin interesting about it at the
launch of a console yeah I mean looking
at look if you look at the you know
switch with the switch light right
switch I came out two years after the
launch of the switch I think that it's
they're gonna be relatively around the
same strength it's just one I think
one's gonna be dis list and what's not I
think they're going to take like you
know the the little luxury things out of
the lockhart to make it more price
relevant I think Microsoft's gonna take
a loss on both oh yes sure
I mean honestly we talked about this I I
was all-in when they first started
talking about it because I wanted them
to make sure they could never lose that
power narrative again so how better to
do that intimation you have both ends of
the spectrum covered but then Anil and
then we heard the rumors about
PlayStation potentially doing it and
then why I felt that wasn't a good move
because PlayStation didn't need to do
PlayStation can get away with slightly
less powerful console because of their
name and because of their names like
they can get away with that hmm
I don't think Xbox could get away with
that right but then thinking on it after
was like man you know what you don't
want to confuse people and you don't
want to be you don't want to put
something out there and if the messaging
which has traditionally not been the
greatest it's not perfectly on point
it's gonna create problems it's gonna
create problems and you don't want that
type of confusion at the launch of your
next if you were deciding how they
market this how would you market because
it is it is a channel it's like do you
Margaret now and do do you market just a
la carte and you expect the hardcore to
know about the Anaconda like how do you
I can tell you how they market it if you
have any for me to go easy not go right
ahead because it is
it's not even confuse its to me you
listen not everyone has a 4k TV still
don't have 4k so you could literally
mark it anaconda as the big boy 4k 60
machine and you can mark it this one has
the 1080p if you don't you don't care
about that they're both gonna have ssdna
both gonna have you Navi architecture
and I'm saying and here's the thing the
rumor that came out people like oh you
don't saying why they saying it'll be
comparable teraflop wise to annex less
than an accent lesson and apply our
PlayStation 4 pearl different it's a
different thing for you and in a shot
the mods all teraflops are not the same
it has exactly the performance of this
would be superior to that X and and the
ps4 if you had faithful pro so that's
the thing I mean this is really simple
you could say look IE for those of you
who just want a machine that does 1080p
60 or even the rumor of 1440p 60 which
is I'm doing and I'm Sam you know this
is this is the machine for you it'll
have a lower clock as far as the the CPU
you don't saying maybe less rain I may
do how right I just say you just say
that this is if you don't care about 4k
gaming this is the 1080p 60 I just feel
like running running ads and stuff
you're gonna have two different versions
of an ad like I feel like it's gonna get
complicated like yeah it shout-out to
dizzy dizzy you saying stop saying
consumers buying ignorantly how is it
confusing because not it's not confusing
to me it's not confusing to you we're a
different beast than the average person
and welcome to buy a console and it's be
Frank you know not everybody's gaming
Forte behind that counter not everybody
knows absolutely absolutely telling
these consoles they have no idea how to
describe them but here's my counter to
both of you in this sense we're doing
this right now with phones when you get
the new galaxy there's like four
galaxies you got the s9 yep but do that
problem oh all the girls are still at
launch at the same time the nine and the
nine plus you don't see like this has
been going on you know say this is not
new because usually all that's the
difference between one is the size of
the screen why not
the nine-plus had the whole feature of
the edge being a textile technology they
are a different thing but they don't
I've never seen them break down they're
like where's the to mark yeah the
phone's more expensive than the consoles
do you know how much discourse you know
say like this is everyone's buying the
new iPhone everyone's buying the new
Galaxy phones they don't just dish out
eight nine that's why Microsoft has a
program for you you know I'm gonna jump
in go for this we're not gonna confuse
the message in that Microsoft has had in
the past with the games that they have
learned now I've seen a different way of
messaging um you know shout out to Aaron
Greenberg in the team I've seen a
different level of control internally
with the company right so moving forward
these leaks are some most of these leaks
are strategic to be honest with you and
the fact that now all Frenchie's in New
Jersey um the the reason why now
we're starting to hear about the
Lockhart and the stuff is to prepare the
people going forward
they won't market the high system for it
they're not gonna market it they're not
gonna market the Anaconda at a certain
price when I want to go trade in my
phone I'm glad kognito brought that up I
went to go trade in my phone my phone's
paid off so I'm like I want the new one
and we're gonna do it last year chimera
and I was talking about the 5g you know
galaxy s 10 and then once we found out
how much 5g was we was like you don't
need to jump I don't care about the
screen and all that other stuff right
not necessary so we helps that fast
now um they're having a little bit more
programs and going forward so when I
went to go check the price on the phone
my phone was like $900 for the base
mm-hmm but when I say okay let me max
that out let me get the you know the
bigger RAM and all this other stuff they
came up to 1600 I said what are you out
of your mind
like what is what's going on here all
right so we know that this they're gonna
market the LA car
that's the only one that you need to
market it brings the people in the store
you market the 399 system and I believe
attic is right I believe it'll be 399 I
know I don't never see it coming in at
299 that's what you think from for
pocket watches and I won't believe it it
be 349 because if it's going to be any
price is going to be a whole price not a
half because that's what you cut you got
you cut the half okay all right so it's
gonna be a whole price so it would be
the $400 right the PlayStation 2 come in
at five then a la carta probably come in
six 650 right now that's when you want
to maximize your dollar that's when you
want to go higher right the reason why
the cheaper Lockhart will sell and
undercut Sony is because we know that
they gain foothold in being $100 cheaper
when you go to the store and people are
purchasing for the holiday season
they're trying to get the most of the
can when they can how they can't so you
must have supply that's the first and
foremost they must have supply you must
have price point if your hundred dollars
cheaper than your competition it gives
you a better chance to survive now for
us enthusiasts who want something a
little bit more beefier a little bit
more powerful a little bit more premium
you're gonna go and you're gonna get the
Anaconda that's the stuff that we know
about now
after a period of time you can market
the power differential between the other
competition right later but in the
beginning right it's going to be on
equal footing with all of them because
of the CPU and the SSD and the RAM
involved right so that's what I said
earlier when I said I think they're
gonna market the Lockhart like oh don't
make people wire the Anaconda but
Lockhart's going to be in the spotlight
how does that how does that work with
the Lockhart being in the spotlight same
way worse Atomics in the Earth's right
obviously I'm not at the launch of a new
platform how do you market the Lockhart
when it's obviously inferior to the PS 5
right but see the thing is is that the X
and the pro have made that market a
little bit more understanding -
difference
like when they made that two years into
the site war two or three years into the
cycle it doesn't matter when they made
it they still gave people the option and
they've lived with that that option for
a couple years now it's a different
animal at the long-term when I go to
purchase I'm going to go well I'm gonna
go purchase as much as I can and then
I'm going to put them on eBay like I do
know what I'm gonna do what i'ma keep
for myself is I'm going to turn this
down
that's the boiler mom what i'ma keep for
myself is I'm going to keep to
Lockhart's one Lockhart down here one
Lockhart in the bedroom the bedroom and
inside the liberal where I gained mostly
I'm going to keep the anaconda right
hold a wall right so to [ __ ] at JD
gamer how powerful you think the
Lockhart will be Xbox one X was in CPU
and then shout out to brat Wow
with the $20 which I Wow because he
wanted to say all of that and had it
your bones are different it's a tangible
device with people immediately see the
screen size difference it can hold the
devices and physically see differences
consoles are a bit more complaint
complicated than that to market so but
here's the thing and I'll get to brat
but I mean I'll give it back to is that
this has happened before you know I'm
saying the 360 launched with an arcade
and then what you got a skew the
PlayStation 3 had 16 core console it was
just a different and hard drive so I'm
trying to say the the processor dual
school of dual skew has existed this is
not new this is not something that has
never happened before that question I
think this is different than that this I
think this is different because this is
two different products that's been
that's being put together not really two
different posting you're gonna dodge the
Glock are in anti corner 2 different
products a 360 168 are we gonna say are
we gonna send the Xbox one X and the
answer the same product It's My Thing
it was fought from from a technical
standpoint they are the same one is just
going to have most likely a higher clock
you know I'm saying on on their CPU as
far as the ant economy is concerned you
know I'm saying and then we got to see
obviously the hard drives we know they
both share an SSD it's not going to be
as different as so many people think
it's just the price point one is going
to
we allow you to play 4k games before ke
gaming and the other is not it's simple
like it truly is when I play Mason and
he's playing on his s and I'm playing on
my ex it doesn't bother him at all
you know because he doesn't care about
4k gaming but I do I'm that person that
care about that graphic horse stuff he
doesn't care about that
now if it would be a big problem if they
didn't have an SSD drive inside a black
hole are you talking different now if
there's no s I don't think it's going to
get the Fox you got a roll right no it's
cool bro that's cool bro
please man shout your channel out let
the people know where they can find you
you're there because the laws that
continue talking so we got I just want
to say thank you gentlemen so much for
having me on your chat it's been super
fun and a pleasure and yeah come check
me out at out of the flannel fox on
youtube or the cigar noob if you want to
Huff some stuff Fox I just want to say I
can't wait to get a chance to hang out
with you and eat those crabs and those
lobsters in Boston on this pax run and
it was definitely a pleasure meeting you
and the conversations we have before we
even launch was even more entertaining
and the stuff that we had going on hell
yeah man I'm looking forward to some
crab legs bro what about riddles bag
enjoy your day brother thank you guys so
much no doubt we could tell you shout
out to the JD gamer with the file our
super chat the way they market is
platform marketing you say join the
platform with the most powerful hardware
and you join the platform with the best
price so continue Kay I'm sorry intro to
you no no no I'm JD definitely is on to
something JD I definitely appreciate
your thoughtful comment and you know I'm
super chat because that's exactly how
you market it right you know when you
purchase it to market so if you're
purchasing into an ecosystem
you know Perkis purchasing into a
console platform per se you're
purchasing into all the services and
everything that is incumbents in that
ecosystem so if they have affordability
and power inside the ecosystem you have
a choice to choose which one
it's going to be best for you so they're
not telling you all right well this is
here and this is where you play it and
this is it this is that's not the
end-all be-all how you definitely move
inside that ecosystem is totally up to
you because at some point in time
they're gonna be able to allow you to
take that same experience onto your PC
see people are forgetting that once
you're in and those games are launching
first they day and date inside game pass
game passes travel into the new system
game pass is still on your PC so day and
date those games will be available on PC
so what are you saying they're gonna
market three platforms no they're
marketing the ecosystem and they're
marketing and strategy of best price and
performance here's the thing I want to
finish to solve an attic and it's the
elephant in the room that we're
forgetting is the success right now of
the Xbox at a meeting on Qantas and if
we see right now with the UK right
they just won Black Friday with the all
digital edition of the the Xbox 1s so
the rumor with Lockhart is that is going
to be most likely a diskless platform
again an attempt to bring the price down
now my question to both of you is don't
you think they would be excellent be
more emboldened right now that they seem
physically says because we all agreed
that the concept was cool but the price
was stupid at launch we felt that the
price was too high but now that they
brought that price down and now they're
seeing a success of this price being at
that point and consumers like yo I'll
buy a diss list Xbox they beat out to
switch and PlayStation and black front
with the S digital that's it you got to
think in the region to I think about the
region and that's impressive in the
region because they've never been over
there so it shows if people if the price
is low enough and right that's that's
where I think it's gonna be a $400
console it's not gonna be $150 but when
you look when you're looking at the
competition that's five we saw at the
beginning of this gen like that hundred
all the difference is a bit it's a lot
to a lot of people right like that will
you know motivate it especially if you
look from a hardcore stay
that point you know there's some that
don't necessarily need the $600 well
that might go with the huh the hundred
dollar lesson by a game with one
question a Udo attic is this way I think
mean you are different is that the price
has to be substantially different it
can't be just a hundred dollars because
it's gonna be two hundred okay it'll be
two hundred from the Xbox but and you
know we might disagree but I think that
I think that they're gonna go just this
and they're gonna for standard
mechanical to George I for the law car
because they're gonna have to trick
they're gonna have to get that two
hundred and I think it's gonna be really
hard to do it with with an SSD and like
I'm really doing SSD I'm gonna do with
you drive that's just a hard drive but
it's more expensive
yeah but that's more the prices have
started to fall off of them to be honest
with you they they started to get to a
point where the prices on the parts of
the SSDs are falling to the floor now
the speed of the SSD is totally
different but the standard SSDs now are
coming in at a little bit cheaper and I
mean we gotta go up like a 500 gig SSD
you go just so you can have more of a
mechanical drive that has high your gig
gigabytes or terabytes without costs
raising the cost of I think as integral
as they say it is it has to be it has to
because then you you are actually
changing the functionality of the
machine at that it has to be so five
hundred I think five hundred is that
sweet you think it's not enough but I
know it's not enough but has a midterm
we have a game right now that's a
hundred and twenty and that's the turbo
right but but at air about a terabyte
SSD right there's cost your safe of
course they might even they might go
lower with the with the SSD side drive
size which is a yeah I mean I can either
see it being like 500 gigabytes are like
a two terabyte mechanical Tron
that's that's where I am right now I'm
sorry that that's where I am
rumor is that is definitely gonna be an
SSD no one knows the size though
they the rumor at both consoles are
going to have the SSD they're gonna have
the Navi system but again the rumor also
is that I mean the rumor was Lockhart
got kids so I get really good no it
never really went away they just said
from the true inside shout out to
dealers shout out to on Brad Sam's you
know I'm saying like a lot Ian shot -
Jes Gordon it never went away there was
only a few outlets saying that but it
was always it's just that if you put it
with a pin they tried to pin Phil down
to it and say yo we heard rumors he said
look we want to just talk about the
console the antic on that s'what we're
willing to talk right now
we got to get some did we get the world
by JD gamer defied all the super chat no
we got $5 supercell JD gamer the way
they market we said that one so then we
gotta get um get one bad mother-- we got
a $5 super champ from one bad mother
says Lockhart makes next-gen SSD and
CPUs more accessible accessibility and
options is good for the consumer speed
up innovate and it adopt faster that's
what I gotta be at the end of the day
all I'm gonna say is this like like we
said with the whole thing you know I
thought it was interesting that they did
very well with a disc list console right
so coming in to the next generation you
know I'm saying do you think of for like
the standard price with a distance
console do you think it's like it's
doing good now at the end of this gen
but at the beginning of a jam when
people don't have the esses in the x's
do you take a distance console with what
their their base entry is gonna be a
good idea I think if they can show first
of all they have to the price point for
is at that point
at that point if you have if you give
everyone the option to buy a console
without a disc and not given the option
to buy with the disc cuz the disc would
be the Anaconda yeah but you know when
you could just pay an extra hundred
dollars and get a ps5 that has a disc
drive they might not pay the extra $200
for the pure for the next X bone we
don't know the price points we don't
know the price point on what Lockhart's
gonna be we don't know the price point
of what psi we're assuming well I hope
to god they're not the same price right
so that's where I'm in agreement with
you
that if they do this with a diskless
Lockhart right that does gotta be okay
it's questions that epiphany let's go
let's have a question wonderful
Microsoft is truly aggressive right
right and a la carte comes in at a
hundred dollars cheaper than the
PlayStation five but then a Conda comes
in to same prices to pray the same price
as deprived and is more powerful because
this time they're not shoehorn in their
connect inside of the box this time you
have a different person in the helmet
that wants to be aggressive it doesn't
want to lose price point because people
are talking about right now that you
have the development kits out there in
the PlayStation 5 it's a little bit more
powerful at this point and we all know
that Microsoft falls behind when the
comments to dev kits and then as it
starts to get closer those those kids
that I think that purposely they
remember you
yeah they're waiting to the very last
minute minute yeah PlayStation to really
show their hand right and then you're
gonna make tweaks here to there I think
in the next three or four months we'll
see PlayStation Plus alright so more
important part is my more important part
oh not the dev kits yeah it's the prices
right now what if the Lockhart is that
hundred dollars cheaper and then
anaconda does come in at the same exact
price resident station Fox aggressive
that's what happens that's aggressive
that that to me is the play if Flockhart
is going to exist right and this is the
rumor that it's not dead it has to do
that like that to me to play to me the
anaconda has to at least match the
PlayStation 5 on price point what I'm
saying but more if it's more that lock
are better be substantial happens if
they do that do you think the end the
kana can beat them in power if it's the
same price how much of a loss is
Microsoft willing to take and we don't
know there's no chance if you're
thinking about it this way right let's
get the super chat button um if you're
thinking about it this way Microsoft
will make all that money back off of the
fact that game pass will be in each and
every person's box right that's the one
that was in the game pastor that yeah
you know I think I think next-gen we've
seen a push on game s but next gen
they're really gonna push
now right they force jPAS is gonna be in
every box a month of it now think about
this let's go back to LA car for a
second think about that lowest price
between and I know we gonna get there
and gate pass in the box let's say they
do some promote like three months a game
pass or one month the game pass for the
guys that just buy a la carte digital
that's an attractive deal yeah let's get
like soup pixel bit G I'll get the first
one
I think the la carte comes in at 299 and
used a hybrid SSD HSD with h HDD with
SSD Ram disk with three months of game
pass that's the key PlayStation 4 $500
on placing five five dollars and Nick's
xbox $500 who got JD game that would be
extremely competitive
yes dr. JD gaming with the $10 super
chat nobody want to pay more for less
that's why Xbox lost this gen it's also
why ps3 lost in the beginning of last
gen this wrong price to performance
attack is the classic pincer and you can
expect to win I'll get this one we got
the fighter for physical pit Locker it
has to be a significant value
proposition take that up front and then
make it up in gamepad let's run take the
elbow I know for like I know for a fact
everything in me is saying that they're
taking the L on both consoles like
they're gonna take that on both consoles
right we gonna fly through this thing
we're just gonna fly through Brown your
Lord returns will they be Thrones so are
we gonna skip the video yes okay we're
here are the nominees age of Wonders
planet for a No 1800 Fire Emblem three
Harlem for three kingdoms
Tropico six and war group I got fire
them fire I'm gonna fire them think
that's a free that's a free W for
everyone freebie that's Fire Emblem
okay next up best sports slash racing
game the nominees are Crash Team Racing
nitro fueled rally 2.0 huge football Pro
Evolution Soccer 2020 mmm-hmm 1 2019 and
FIFA 20 all right my fee foot this next
one we're gonna disagree let's go score
and music first up cadence of Hyrule
nope
death stranding Devil May Cry 5 mm-hmm
March 3 sayonara wild hearts wow I'm
going kena March 3 I'm going with addict
with the Kingdom Hearts 3 sir
Oh me a kegger on the W score and music
it's a sign our wall house is about
music and then you know what it is dead
look man soundtracks don't hate you
quality no market I have a feeling that
trainees gonna win a lot look I told you
guys and I want to win this Kingdom
Hearts is no game you know what I gotta
think with a cold heart yeah Kingdom are
all the good of a good gift great of a
go over the side our wild hearts I heard
things about that shout the right
emperor with the $2 of joy here to show
love to the ILP Resident Evil 2 gave me
no doubt alright next all playing game
of the year this is gonna be hard
disco Elysium final fantasy xiv Kingdom
Hearts 3 the Monster Hunter world ice
born and the outer world alright I got
out of worlds I got out of worlds
might hurt disco leave me only on PC so
I'm thinking outer worlds that's what
I'm alright
player no one shot the game so I want
everybody in the chat feel free to put
your vote in the chasity Jed - lets go
next up performance voice acting Ashly
Burch that's providing da world doing
this category Cortney hope as Jesse fade
in control
nope Laura Bailey as Kate da I want to I
want to vote for Courtney could see that
redhead voice BB up done
continue don't be B mu that don't go
everyone let me just say everyone in the
chat will get to super chance right at
the end of the show we had to speed so
then we have Mads Mikkelsen as cliff
death stranding mm-hmm Matthew peretta
a case a aka Alan Wake as doctor for
darling control hmm and we have Norman
Reedus buddy what's funny he's going for
the UH the easy I'm going for the easy
bargain with cliff I want to go with
Kate but I'm trying to go for this
double I try to go for the L okay I'll
go I'm gonna body
I'm going to a body I'm or Ashley burn
game apex legends destiny - I know I'm
going before team fortnight and Tom
Clancy's Rainbow six siege this is wrong
I lose I'm gonna lose I'm gonna destined
Emma lose okay I'm down with my sword
I'm going Final Fantasy 14 mm-hmm wow
I'm want to say fortnight I must say I'm
not Lance these out here
I'm saying fortnight I'm antsy I don't
know how many you know I know people
work for tonight I'm only person in your
destiny no mana project narrative a play
tale innocence true death stranding
mmm-hmm disco Elysium mm-hmm and the
outer worlds I'm Google okay
landing Annie - lets go he's lost here
[Applause]
when you're looking at the gold plague
tale I've heard amazing things about of
play tales yeah I heard that too it was
really nice bushes
multiplayer game apex legends
Borderlands three open call of duty
modern warfare call of duty hmm 99
mm-hmm Tom Clancy's did you really even
have to say Tetris to win this we want
this w okay everybody call of duty they
know I mean we gonna I'm gonna go cuz I
feel our duty never wins in the world I
think the game was got something against
I'm gonna land on this make are gonna
lose this thing
yeah you know we men doing mobile
because they don't have Garrett gougeres
pop-pop's women on the show
all right s independent game mob is you
disco Elysium guitar sample ours is hard
outer watch you said I'm going on routes
to me it's either out of wilds disco or
game categories this one to game the
main I get so there will be game this
category that are in that one as well
I'm told I like disco but I heard so
much about I'm gonna go out of worlds
I'm garbage is only on one platform
that's the only thing it just goes to
the narrative which I'm going for now so
we get back games for impact
concrete Genie time words life is
strange to expose to ah unkind word the
concrete genie don't want to go conquer
genies well then go further you know I'm
going I gotta go the safe thing okay all
I can say is still misfits but not so
cool I'll get you JD game I forget you
game Direction next yeah game Direction
control death stranding hmm
Resident Evil 2 Akito shadows died twice
not a while alright this is where I'm
Globo and I'm going I'm getting back in
Pocket with desperation
woo you already lost like
this is weird now I get back in line
part of me part of me wants to go to
give them I'm gonna go listen we cannot
stay here and kill this Jenny no wait
let's be real here we're only going with
it because of the game is here like if
Dutch Chinese is nominated we all have
to look at and be like it could really
win that by some way this is always
reppin the the studio not the game per
se
so it's own for disco Elysium other
studio for grease toast entertainment
for my friend in Mobius digital for out
of wild crit for slay the spire and
house house for unsaddle news game fresh
I know he said I'm going on tie to lose
game young game I think this is the one
cook I'm gonna own disco easiest goose
what is interesting some interesting
fighting game dead of 6mm jump force
noisy combat 11 MRI showed
Super Smash Brothers on smash pity award
I'm giving this match I think I think
that's the only safe bet here because I
don't think Mortal Kombat's winning and
I don't even know why jump forces on
here I literally haven't heard one
person talk about dead or alive 6 and I
have no clue with that Samurai Shodown
game is so on the game luigi's mansion 3
Adventure is a super mario maker too
hard
Smash Brothers ultimate yo crafted world
wow this is hard
this is smash all day long smash smash
smash because it's like these are all
like ring fit is it this is my big thing
this is gonna be the the war day now
it's between commercials and [ __ ] smash
I'm standing pocket community supports
the rich Chung of broadcasted who went
under the table yeah yeah we'll do that
alright apex legends destiny - final
fantasy xiv for and Tom Clancy's Rainbow
six siege I'm dying on a sword you know
I'm gone I don't care I go for tonight
[Music]
one of those fortnight might win them
both but I'm at least one on one and the
deaf community is outage over
transparency yeah yeah exactly when you
look at the description I think destiny
I'm going to see goddess
all right duty modern warfare hmm
control mmm death stranding here's five
Resident Evil 2 this is a tough was a
tough role shadows die twice I'm going
with evil I'm going to Sakura shadow die
twice but this is the shot they got
alright
everybody's in the okay rate or
direction you have control stranding
Greece sign our Walt Hart's sucky Roche
out of that twice
the legend of zelda links awakening gold
my heart because i have it i love this
game and I haven't wrapped it yet
control I got a little Russian stranding
I want to go zelda bonus i mean it's the
wouldn't man dared s churning hopefully
i'll get lucky you know give test ready
every now and then cool achievement they
don't matter man that going with the
straining look be you says some suspects
stuff on this so far okay go with that
strategy i need to catch up okay you
breaking protocol something i'm sitting
here playing Zelda and it pops up right
now and if I'd be a fool to go against
my pick actually alright
action-adventure game Borderlands 3
control death stranding Resident Evil 2
the legend of zelda links awakening
sakura shadows i twice
you could take about what you take and
I'm taking a Zelda here would be funny
if he lost both people because I'm going
with Resident Evil 2 because I feel like
this is the only one they're gonna win
I'm going with Sakura
I'm gonna check a row - I'm gonna take
an L on this one this could go either
way on a key some scenarios for all of
these winning on some I'm going uh
they're stranding and in art direction
but right here I'm gonna go with action
intervention wait up action game all
right we have apex legends Nash chain
call of duty modern warfare mmm Devil
May Cry five gears five Metro Exodus I
got I got I got a step on the the sword
of Xbox inside gears five dinosaur kind
of agree with you man but I something
about that Call of Duty's is it for some
reason I think that I think it's either
Gears of Devil May Cry like I really do
I would like what's it again ask your
trades here and they might've I died on
my sword Owen Astrachan I'm dying
I noticed knock on win I know it's not
gonna I beat there devil may cry so I'm
gonna go with Devil May Cry is a really
or two points right we gotta see it
Nizar control death stranding Resident
Evil 2 Secura shadows die twice Smash
Brothers ultimate and the outer worlds
on goner Sakura
we all know if the fix is in what's
gonna happen if the fix is that we start
with the fix but I can't give resident
evil as much as it's great it's like
that game was good just keep going
versus everybody is not for everybody
and Cognito go death stranding on my
soul that W don't care about your mom
principal okay I'm going to get Jeffery
the game of core to get super [ __ ]
with the game I gotta stand on my square
second row a little my squid god bless
you I'm gonna go with their stranding
even though I know outer world is the
winner
I'm just gonna sit here and tell you the
truth I love King outdoors would be my
personal but I just don't see them to be
honest I loved outer worlds but I don't
think has any right being on this list
well I'm gonna take this young baby mood
I don't think I don't think that's your
any control and outer worlds long this
list
I Loki don't think smash belongs on here
he's don't belong nobody's supposed to
be Jedi fall in order
I think there's five should be on that
winning Game of the Year his man has
AIDS boon [ __ ] is my
no I didn't you know what looking at the
recognizing a game that delivers the
absolute best experience across all
creative and technical fields King is
gonna win this way because it's crowded
Lord he has stuck to the popular why the
desk Ronnie doesn't want to one award if
they go against the grade because they
guilty Jima is out here he gonna take
trophies home he's gonna go up there for
the game with you boy
all right look man we didn't have time
to put him up here five or six times you
want this this this is this award you
have to look at the live chat thing the
loud shake help find it for me because
that's what I want to respect them I got
state $60 super chat all I have to say
is the one I don't have one after that
in the chest let me fall under we got it
was JD he was talking about I remember
it was something about the consoles and
he just put it back in the regular chat
if he's there yeah because we want to
shout you out brother all right it is
the 299 Lockhart half the memory GPU and
down clock to reduce cost of cooling and
Akata twice the ps5 memory and 50%
faster CPU with CPU 10 cores and 30 more
GPU
I just dominate I just want to point out
JD if I butchered that it's cause like
on the on the other screen that you have
to look at super Chester really small
you can't really like get to scroll down
it so that's why it was a little bit
harder than human nasty regarding
horizon zero dawn having a PC police
turns out to be true how does that
affect your view regarding Sony first
party exclusives moving forward the
choices are a don't like this direction
Sony first party should remain exclusive
to their platform be this is the future
of gaming benefits Sony financially and
more gamers play the game or C I don't
care until it's my favorite Sony
exclusive that is there for PC JD we
would love to have Jeff on here advice
come about to fix
daddy highly tell you what every go you
know what everyone in the chat tweet
Jeff to say come on I have to recuse
myself go on Twitter tweet Jeff and say
come on IOP Tagus again it was fantastic
to have a minute around Lord addict
wicked if I people find you what you
have going on sir you can find me review
and Pokemon to the next couple of days
uh I don't even know how I'm gonna
approach this but uh we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out together as a
community you can find me nowhere I
gotta go to work in the making that's
that's how that's how Keys gonna come to
the IOP next week when you can find me
on Twitter I'll hear actively bashing
trolls in the mouth
Oh King David OTW Hey and you yes this
doesn't make you upset right you like
the pocket watch it roll there you go oh
no I don't like the support of all the
people that's out here I really love to
see all of your guys um collection it
was really phenomenal it was us things
that I've seen in a long time I saw a
guy who actually had the the old school
of Dreamcast and everything had it he
CRT television and we started off be
from but we follow each other now and
I'm looking at this collection is
beautiful stuff um guys keep collecting
keep doing each other doing I can see
Kos oh I got some other stuff I have
some stuff in a box that I'm gonna put
out um soon I'm gonna do something
different for you guys a little loads of
gaming down net where I'm water
I think buses is behind in these gaming
reviews and stuff like that in the very
Arkansas guys no joke actually to be
honest with you we have superior writers
that are their teams fire and I'm not
saying because I'm watching a calling
part of it but I'm saying it because
it's true and go to the teespring store
and go get those just definitely and
make sure you tune in to the last word
if you into destiny and stuff I mean
okok and Laura Montes is spilling all
the tea and give me new everything that
y'all need to know going forward we got
a fun last word up with TZ Teddy for IGN
fireteam chat associate you know I'm
saying it was hilarious please check it
out if you want your season of dawn fix
again like King said Lords of gaming
Dianetics where is that right now man we
are bubbling we're cooking salute to all
the riders centering on Jean Schafer um
gondolas condor dizzy undead it's just
if we moving baby is moving there's so
many names I can't even we are
man bike Peter truth anchorman it's
crazy
Rosie Lloyd's game with that net please
support when you see the articles up man
retreating mines
Lord mines the technical Lord you know
saying you already know what it is so
yeah please support and get a chat with
fantastic over like 150 are today
outstanding again the final Fox no doubt
salute next week we will be doing most
likely hopefully me an act will do a
live stream of the game voice and then
next Sunday crown your Lord who will be
the winner will Kings frauding earn him
his first crown your Lord don't worry
man I do not pay your father I'm right
there why do you say that is the
question you already
[Music]
okay can you gotta tell you got tell
these people the truth last year we took
this L hard alright we knew next year
that happening again first year was cogs
this year's addict itself you already
know everybody enjoy your evening thanks
for rocking now we are out of here